l'ukraine a borodianka près de kiev il y
a plus de victimes civiles cab ucia
selon le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky 26 corps ont été retrouvés hier
par les secouristes dans deux immeubles
la russie multiplie ses attaques pendant
ce temps dans le sud et l'est du pays on
retrouve tout de suite sylvain rousseau
notre envoyé spécial à lviv après
l'annonce une offensive imminente
majeure des russes dans l'est on
s'attend à un afflux de réfugiés dans la
ville
oui alors il faut savoir que les
réfugiés n'ont jamais cessé d'affluer
vers la ville de lviv cette grande ville
de l'ouest ukrainien qui sert de plaque
tournante entre l'ukraine et la pologne
voisine à peine à plus de 80 kilomètres
au début du conflit il était environ
30000 arrivée quotidiennement et ils
étaient encore sept mille à arriver à
peu près 7000 à arriver chaque jour
avant même les annonces du gouvernement
avant même la demande qu'a fait le
gouvernement aux civils de quitter
urgemment l'est du pays et le dombass en
prévision d'une grande douve d'une
offensive russe de grande ampleur sur
sur la région alors ces réfugiés nous
avons pu les rencontrer hier il s'agit
essentiellement de femmes d'enfants de
personnes âgées qui ont tout laissé
derrière eux qui ont tout perdu la
situation humanitaire à lviv restent
pour l'instant sur contrôle puisque ces
gens arrivent à se faire héberger soit
dans des centres d'hébergement soit dans
de la famille ou des amis ou alors la
pub certains quittent même le pays vers
je vous le disais vers la pologne
voisine il faut savoir qu'un train un
train humanitaire était était prévu deux
pour arriver à lviv hier en train avec
près de 4000 personnes à bord mais ce
train qui quittait le dombass que n'a
pas pu arriver puisque la voie ferrée a
été
bombardé mais nous avons pu lire
discuter avec les autorités locales de
lviv pour l'instant il nous assure que
la situation est sous contrôle et qu'une
nouvelle arrivée type de réfugiés est
pas un problème ils seront répartis
ensuite dans toute la région de l'ouest
ukrainien la présidente de la commission
européenne ou sous la forme d'un la
haine et le chef de la diplomatie jose
morales sont attendus ce vendredi à kiev
comment est perçue cette visite par les
ukrainiens
oui effectivement il suit vous l'avez
dire qui doit arriver à kiev alors c'est
symboliquement c'est important d'autant
qu'elle s'était prononcée pour une
adhésion rapide de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne mais globalement pour les
gens ici tout ça ça ne compte pas
vraiment on est vraiment dans la
symbolique c'est un peu comme les les
nouvelles sanctions européennes c'est
avec eux que les gens attendent ici on
est on est vraiment dans l'immédiat on
s'intéresse plus à on réclame qu'on fait
ce que réclame d'ailleurs le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky
c'est-à-dire un soutien militaire plus
conséquent des armes une zone
d'exclusion aérienne ici on s'inquiète
surtout de ce que va devenir l'est et le
sud du pays en cas d'offensive offensive
de grande ampleur de la russie et on
sait que cette cette offensive
normalement devrait démarrer dans les
jours peut-être même dans les heures qui
viennent merci beaucoup aux sylvain vous
soumet